I want to start by asking you about
Thomas Cullen ins book the beguiled
which was actually published a long
while ago what if the book give you a
source material and what are its
limitations in terms of what you wanted
to do with it um yeah I went through the
book and just learn more about the
different characters then I had to edit
down the characters I was going to focus
on because we're more in the book and
just decided who I was going to focus
and kind of distill the story down most
of adapting a book is really editing it
and what can work to tell a film story
because you have to make it into a film
that becomes a different thing and then
and part of is also being free with it
to imagine the story going in other
direction so I I can't even remember
what it is from the book and what is
from my imagination we mentioned the
bathing bathing scene I don't think it's
in the book I guess imagined you know we
had to make it a steamy as possible but
I yeah I just loved the whole premise of
it and then I read more of the you know
I got more of the backstory of the
character even things about certain
characters that aren't actually in the
film I was able to talk to the actors
about about their you know histories
that might inform more about the
characters and this is the kind of book
that I can imagine a lot of Hollywood
executives saying great premise let's
set it in the future during an alien
invasion or let's set it in some other
war why is it important to you to
preserve its Civil War setting yeah
there was a moment where because
Universal on the rights and you know
someone said to Oh could you said it you
know reinterpreted and said at some
other time but to me it's just the
premise is just so loaded that it's um
during the Civil War to wartime and they
take it an enemy soldier and and it's so
claustrophobic and and it just it just
makes the whole thing even in the in the
south with the heat and the sexual
repression I just part of it was so I
just wanted to delve into that world and
also in the South the way that women
were you know supposed to be how much
manners and being a lady was so
important and then in all of a sudden
there's no men around to be
ladies four and and and they're kind of
in this brutal times or you know they
could go against their their ladylike
nature so so so much of the atmosphere I
think came from the south and I was
really excited to do a movie set at that
time Kirsten how much time did you guys
have to kind of look at what period
behavior was the way women dress the way
they talk to each other the way they
behaved I'm dressed very scandalous
shown a lot of ankle a lot well so am I
going on a Sox on all three of em yeah
we're just what we most movies have done
with Sophia we kind of have this it's
getting to know each other but at the
same time we're learning things like how
to bandage a wound and we had Bible
study and dance classes and i weirdly
remember because it's something so weird
to me you can never pick up your dress
like that you have to swoosh it over and
then hold it with the other hand
so that was something that was just an
etiquette with yeah little etiquette
yeah we did etiquette classes how to
address you know each other
little girls little girls don't call
each other miss but you know obviously
when they talk to me or miss Martha so
all of those manners
Yuri there is a team that Sophia works
with you're among them that is very
close-knit and that spends a lot of time
together editor Sarah flack production
designer and Ross costume designer
stated boot at all women by the way not
coincidental or maybe but what is it
about that team that you find really is
highly functioning in order to execute
Sophia's vision and also work quickly
because you probably only had what 30 40
days to shoot yeah we had played 26 days
OCA and there's a shorthand you know and
Sophia said this earlier she said you
know when you find people what did you
say about when you when you find your
team you said it took the foot somebody
gave you advice early on first 10 years
find your team and you did and and so
anyways I feel like there's with an Ross
and Sarah
and Philippe was the new this was the
first time Philippe was was a shooting
film for you but it's I think you want
to work with people that that you can
trust and I think that part of my job as
a producers to create an environment for
Sophia to be able to do her thing and
create an environment on set and you
know setting it up properly whether we
had 30 days or 40 days or in this case
26 days which was a bit nerve-wracking
yeah I remember we'd lose little girls
all the time
okay I'd be like acting too different
it'd be like we've run out of time with
her how are we going to do because we
have limited hours yeah so there were
challenges there for sure but but back
to your question I feel like Sophia's
found her her team and and we're lucky
to be part of it so Cara I want to ask
you about working with Sophia and what
you find rewarding as an actor when you
work with the director repeatedly and
what that means to you to have her
behind a camera when you're performing
well since you know specific and I did
Virgin Suicides together on a 16 it it's
no it's so nice to work with someone
that you've known for that long and that
you have a creative shorthand with and
Sophia and I work in preparation with
the same lady now and so it's kind of
funny so we get to set like we
definitely know where where I should be
and you know i emotionally understand
immediately kind of the vibe sophie is
usually going for and we don't really
need to over explain anything you know
Sophia you're a Kirsten thanks for
coming out